herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
der kanzlerkandidat
eine gewisse siegesgewissheit kann man
ihnen nicht absprechen
allerdings geht es nicht darum umfragen
zu gewinnen sondern wahlen
und 1900
und
1976 hat helmut kohl sogar die erfahrung
machen müssen dass man wahlen gewinnen
kann und danach trotzdem keine koalition
hat
frau bundeskanzlerin
sie haben entschieden hier noch einmal
zu reden sie haben über die leistungen
ihrer kanzlerschaft gesprochen 16 jahre
dem land an vorderster stelle zu dienen
das hat unser aller respekt verdient
dennoch muss man feststellen
am ende ihrer kanzlerschaft ist unser
land nicht in der verfassung
die unseren ansprüchen genügen sollten
vor vier jahren hieß es ein deutschland
in dem wir gut und gerne leben heute
wäre kontinuität das größte risiko für
unser land denn so wie es ist doch erst
nicht wahr
drei krisen corona die flutkatastrophe
und der chaotische abzug aus afghanistan
haben uns allen in diesem sommer noch
einmal vor augen geführt wo die defizite
liegen manche erfinden ja gerne zumal in
wahlkämpfen neue aufgaben für unseren
staat
aber unser staat hat schon viele
aufgaben bundeswehr bildung digitale
infrastruktur und verwaltung justiz
katastrophenschutz und polizei
statt fortwährend neue aufgaben für
diesen staat zu erfinden über
kolleginnen und kollegen sollten wir uns
der staatsaufgaben nummer eins widmen
nämlich wieder funktionieren
die herausforderungen vor denen wir
stehen sind zweifellos groß dringlich
ist dass wir schnellstmöglich in der
pandemie zu einem gesellschaftlichen
normalzustand zurückkehren wie tests und
hygiene konzepten haben wir zum einen
instrumente an der hand zum anderen aber
brauchen wir schnell fortschritte bei
den impfungen wo sind die mobilen im
teams überdies so intensiv gesprochen
wird auf dem campus der universität in
den stadtteilen vor den einkaufszentren
bei sport und
kulturveranstaltungen nicht mehr die
menschen sollten zum impfstoff gehen der
impfstoff muss jetzt zu den menschen
kommen einmal muss es gelingen
einmal muss es doch gelingen dass wir
wort wörtlich vor die welle kommen wir
brauchen nämlich eine politische
garantie dass es in diesem herbst eben
nicht noch einmal zu pauschalen
freiheits einschränkungen nicht noch
einmal zu einem auch nur teilweisen
lockdown kommen der
bundesgesundheitsminister hat unlängst
in einer zeitung gesagt erfordere die
menschen auf nur noch kurz bis zum
frühjahr durchzuhalten ich glaube es ist
die verantwortung der politik dass wir
in diesem herbst schon wieder
gesellschaftliches leben für alle
garantieren können
nach der pandemie müssen wir die
erholung der wirtschaft organisieren die
staatsfinanzen müssen stabilisiert
werden wir müssen tempo machen bei der
digitalisierung um unser land
international konkurrenzfähig zu halten
der demografische wandel macht eine
umstellung unserer sozialsysteme
notwendig und im kampf gegen den
klimawandel
unseren charakter als industrie nation
zu erhalten das wird die aufgabe dieses
jahrzehnts sein denn der kanzlerkandidat
der cdu sagt vor uns stünde ein
erneuerung sun modernisierungs jahrzehnt
dann hat er recht aber was für ein
trauriges zeugnis stellt er damit
zugleich seiner eigenen partei aus die
16 jahre dieses land regiert wird und
dennoch
und dennoch schauen wir nicht mit
pessimismus in die zukunft ganz im
gegenteil wir sind zutiefst davon
überzeugt dass wir diese
herausforderungen nicht nur bewältigen
können sondern das gehen ohne ihnen
chancen liegen wir können sie nicht nur
bewältigen wir können sie zu einem
fortschritt thema unseres landes machen
die kassandra rufer der afg haben
unrecht wenn sie fortwährend die
abstiegs geschichte deutschlands bemühen
dieses land hat unglaublich viel private
initiative dieses land hat unglaublich
viel privates know how dieses land hat
sogar unglaublich viel privates kapital
das problem ist nicht das land das
problem ist eine regierung die dieses
land fortwährend unterfordert und
bürokratisch fesselt
der kanzlerkandidat scholz hat hier eben
eine reihe von garantien gegeben
ökologische und soziale vorhaben
vorgestellt davon hört man viel auch in
diesen wochen von allen politischen
akteuren und ja auch wir als fraktion
der freien demokraten haben soziale und
ökologische vorhaben da wollen wir uns
von niemandem übertroffen übertreffen
lassen und trotzdem herr scholz haben
sie in ihrer sehr umfänglichen rede nur
kursorisch die grundlage jeder sozialen
und ökologischen politik angesprochen
die grundlage nämlich für alle sozialen
und ökologischen ziele die auch sie hier
vorgestellt haben ist ein stabiles
wirtschaftliches fundament ohne eine
starke wirtschaft ist alles was sie auch
an zusagen gegeben haben eine
unrealisierbar
unfinanzierbare träume und deshalb
dürfen wir nicht mehr nur wahlkämpfe mit
mit dem versprechen der ausstellung von
staatlichen leistungen subventionen und
anderen machen sondern wir müssen uns
auch der frage stellen wie dieses land
diese herausforderungen bewältigen kann
wie wir unser wirtschaftliches fundament
stärken sie haben gerade gesagt herr
scholz wir wachsen heraus aus der krise
tatsächlich hatte deutschland im zweiten
quartal 1,5 prozent wachstum aber ist
das tatsächlich die dimension die wir
zur sicherung unseres wohlstands
benötigen für deutschland insgesamt für
dieses jahr 3,4 prozent wachstum
prognostiziert
für die vereinigten staaten von amerika
in dessen sind es sieben für china 8,1
selbst italien wird mit 4,2 prozent
wachstum eine dynamischere wirtschaft
haben als wir das ist keine statistische
größe das ist eine realität er sagt
nicht die opposition es sagen die zahlen
unser land kommt schlechter aus der
krise als die wettbewerber und das zeigt
dass deutschland in den vergangenen
jahren dramatisch an
wettbewerbsfähigkeit verloren hat und
dass meine damen und herren bedeutet
übersetzt millionen von bürgerinnen und
bürger haben schlechtere chancen auf
sozialen aufstieg als anderswo in europa
und der welt aus diesem grund
aus diesem grund kann und darf sich die
politik nicht länger mehr nur auf das
verteilen des wohlstands konzentrieren
da gibt es ja spezialisten dafür wie
sich ausschließlich auf dass verteilung
des wohlstands konzentrieren dieses land
muss aber die frage neu beantworten wie
es diesen wohlstand unter veränderten
bedingungen überhaupt erwirtschaften
deshalb braucht unsere wirtschaft
deshalb braucht unsere wirtschaft einen
kickstart aus der krise wir müssen zur
spitze in der welt aufschließen aber
nicht mit bürokratischen subventionen
oder staatlich gelenkten
konjunkturprogrammen sonderlich mag
wirtschaftliche impulse herr scholz
sie haben hier heute gesprochen über
diejenigen die über steuerentlastungen
sprechen sie haben tatsächlich in einem
höchst steuer land diejenigen hier
kritisiert die entlastung organisieren
wollen sie selbst haben aber geschwiegen
darüber dass ihre fraktion und
diejenigen die ihnen politisch
nahestehen in diesem land bereits
flächige steuererhöhungen organisieren
wollen nach einer wirtschaftskrise
wollen sie für den mittelstand für den
ja auch die einkommenssteuer die
betriebliche steuer ist nach einer krise
in dem viele eigenkapital verloren haben
nach einer krise in dem selbständigen
die altersversorgung haben angreifen
wollen nach einer solchen
wirtschaftskrise wollen sie allen
ernstes einen aufschwung mit
steuererhöhungen organisieren ich sage
ihnen das glatte gegenteil wäre richtig
auf eine wirtschaftskrise antwortet man
mit entlastungen
ein beispiel ein beispiel will
ich will ich will ganz sicher nicht in
jedem punkt auf die britische politik
bezug nehmen aber tatsächlich hat die
regierung im vereinigten königreich nun
ein super abschreibungs programm
vorgelegt
130 prozent abschreibung auf
investitionen im ersten jahr das müssen
wir in deutschland nicht eins zu eins
übernehmen denn so investitions
zurückhaltend sie die britische
wirtschaft sind der deutsche mittelstand
und die deutsche industrie nicht aber
trotzdem sollten wir uns daran
orientieren
konkrete vorschlag ist wir brauchen in
deutschland ebenfalls super abschreibung
geben wir den betrieben eine phase in
der es in der sie hohe investitionen in
die anlagen binnen zwei jahren
abschreiben können so mobilisieren wir
private investitionen in saubere
technologien in investitionen für den
klimaschutz die digitalisierung die
modernisierung unseres landes und sorgen
wir mit einer pause für zusätzliche
bürokratie aller lieferketten gesetzt
dafür dass die betriebe sich auf das
konzentrieren können was jetzt not tut
nämlich die sicherung und die schaffung
von jobs
zur
ökonomischen transformation gehört ist
ja auch die ökologische transformation
mir zu denken wir müssen allerdings
klären in welche richtung wir uns
entwickeln wollen hier in berlin
sprechen sprechen die grünen ja davon
sie wollen aus unserer hauptstadt ein
gut machen ich habe mitunter den
eindruck dass bullerbü auch ihr leitbild
sein könnte für die zukunft unseres
industriestandorts eine ländliche
dorfidylle mit subventionierten
lastenfahrrad aber bei aller liebe bei
aller liebe zu astrid lindgren und
bullerbü ich kann mich nicht erinnern
jemals gelesen zu haben wovon die
eigentlichen villopoto wie leben und
deshalb kann das kein leitbild kann das
kein leitbild für deutschland sein aber
wir können den klimaschutz vorreiter
sein wir müssen es sogar wir können
zeigen dass klimaschutz nicht belasten
das ist die schweiz ist ein mahnendes
beispiel in der schweiz hat selbst an
jüngere generation sich gegen ein
klimagesetz ausgesprochen deshalb weil
sie das gefühl hatten in ihrer freien
lebensführung und in ihren
wirtschaftlichen perspektiven
beschnitten zu werden und genau das
sollte uns auch eine mahnung sein der
führende und einer der führenden
deutschen intellektuellen heinz budde
hat neulich in der ihnen nahe stehenden
tageszeitung taz ein interview gegeben
und bundes sagt zitat ich empfehle dem
grünen milieu einen er
eine nähere beschäftigung mit der fdp
denn angesichts des klimaschutzes droht
das individuum unter die räder zu
geraten und hans bruder hat recht mit
der art und weise wie sie klimaschutz
vorschlagen gerät das individuum mit
seinem recht auf freiheit und
wirtschaftliche perspektive unter die
räder
machen wir uns ehrlich die frankfurter
allgemeine zeitung die patzt einmal
nicht die taz schrieb neulich dass
unsere energie und klimapolitik
inzwischen ein labyrinth sei
von sich zum teil widersprechenden
geboten verboten subventionen anreizen
und programmen fangen wir in dieser
wichtigen aufgabe neu an geben wir ein
klares ziel vor null emissionen im
übernächsten jahrzehnt aber setzen wir
zur erreichung auf die marktwirtschaft
wenn sie hat historisch und
international bewiesen dass sie im
umgang mit knappen ressourcen überlegen
ist im vergleich zu allen anderen
ordnungen und herr scholz sie haben
recht der strombedarf der deutschen
wirtschaft steigt aber nicht alleine nur
die kapazität der energieerzeugung ist
in deutschland entscheidend wir müssen
auch wir die frage nach der
bezahlbarkeit der energie stellen und
deshalb kann das erneuerbare energien
gesetz eben nicht so bleiben wie es ist
und deshalb war es richtig dass in der
vergangenheit so viel lob an cdu und csu
bei den ausbauzielen auch auf den preis
geachtet wird das german engineering
schutz funktioniert zeigt übrigens
nebenbei gesagt die iaa
die deutsche schlüsselindustrie hat sich
längst für ihre zukunftsaufgaben
aufgestellt mit innovativen und sauberen
produkten werden wir auch in zukunft das
autoland nummer 1 sein können und
deshalb brauchte diese industrie mit
ihren milliardengewinnen
auch nichts mehr die subventionen die
nahezu alle fraktionen dieses hauses
unverändert ins schaufenster stellen uns
klar zu sagen es ist absurd dass der
deutsche steuerzahler
auch die e autos für gutverdiener über
den lebenszyklus mit bis zu
20.000 euro fördert während ihr pro
schuljahr und schüler nur
8200 euro in die bildung investieren die
automobilbranche
die automobilbranche bei allem respekt
die bauch technologieoffenheit damit zum
beispiel auch synthetische kraftstoffe
als teil des energie imports im markt
eine chance haben aber die
automobilbranche braucht keine
geldgeschenke der steuerzahlerinnen und
steuerzahler
von einem weg also des verzichts und der
verbote raten wir ab
herr scholz hat ja darauf hingewiesen
dass auch er den wunsch nach prosperität
und wohlstand in anderen weltregionen
respektiert das teile ich aber herr
scholz wenn wir vorreiter sein wollen
dann sollten sie auch in das programm
ihrer partei und das von bündnis 90 die
grünen schauen in diesem programm ist
nämlich nicht davon die rede wir wollen
klimaschutz durch technologie machen
durch marktwirtschaft und fortschritt
sondern überwiegend finde ich auch in
ihrem programm die breite phalanx der
kleinteiligen eingriffe in das
wirtschaftliche und das
gesellschaftliche leben stichwort
tempolimit als ob zb ein tempolimit
einen beitrag zur bekämpfung der
erderwärmung leisten würde es ist
ausschließlich eine wertefrage es hat
keinen beitrag zur bekämpfung der
erderwärmung
es ist nur die werte frage ob man
erwachsenen menschen mündige
entscheidungen verantwortliche
entscheidungen zutraut oder nicht mehr
ist das nicht mein vorschlag
mein vorschlag ist deshalb an andere
warum stellen wir solche kleinteiligen
reglementierungen nicht zur seite im
nächsten jahr wird deutschland den
vorsitz der g20 der pater g 7 haben wir
werden die g7 präsidentschaft haben
machen wir doch das thema klimaschutz
durch technologie machen wir doch
globale partnerschaft bank immer schutz
zum leitgedanken der deutschen g7
präsidentschaft im nächsten jahr wie
ungleich größer wäre das als die
kleinteiligen debatte über tempolimits
in deutschland
schützen wir die handlungsfähigkeit der
nachfolgenden generation aber nicht nur
durch klimaschutz sondern auch durch
solides haushalten
nach corona stehen wir vor
rekordschulden doch liegt es wirklich an
der pandemie wenn man die finanzpolitik
von olaf scholz vor 2020 betrachtet
ergibt sich ein anderes bild denn die
staatsquote ist kontinuierlich gestiegen
2009 10 lag sie bei 45,2 prozent
angesichts von rekord steuereinnahmen
ist viel zu wenig eingesetzt worden für
schuldenabbau und konsolidierung die
bundesausgaben sind in den letzten
jahren doppelt so stark gestiegen wie
die realwirtschaft und zu viele
staatsausgaben sind in konsumtive
bereiche geflossen nicht in
investitionen es ist nicht die
schuldenbremse die uns gehindert hat an
investitionen es waren die politischen
leitentscheidungen für den staatskonsum
lediglich 3,9 prozent der milliarden
steuereinnahmen seit 2013 wir sind in
investitionen geflossen die unser land
moderner gemacht hätten fast 50 prozent
der steuer mehreinnahmen dagegen in den
staatlichen konsum der ehemalige
chefökonom des bmf ludger schuknecht auf
den hätten sie hören sollen der hat
nämlich von einer verdrängung der
investitionen durch den staatlichen
konsum im haushalt gesprochen und davor
gewarnt diese stimme der vernunft musste
auf entscheidung von olaf scholz das
finanzministerium verlassen und das ist
für mich ein deutlicher beleg nicht die
pandemie hat die staatsfinanzen ruiniert
das war zuvor schon die haushaltspolitik
von olaf scholz
die folgen expansive finanzpolitik sehen
wir allerdings schon heute die inflation
liegt bei 3,9 prozent so hoch wie seit
jahrzehnten nicht prognosen gehen von
einem anstieg auf 5 prozent aus und das
trifft kleiner und mittlerer einkommen
das trifft die rentnerinnen und rentner
denen kann man nicht empfehlen wir
jüngeren geht in aktien für die ist es
aufgrund ihrer lebenssituation
möglicherweise gar nicht empfehlenswert
in langfristige anlagen zu gehen die
natürlich auch in der kurzfristigen
betrachtung ein risiko haben wir haben
gerade die rentnerinnen und rentner die
kleinsparer die menschen mit kleinem
einkommen die werden durch inflation
getroffen selbstverständlich hat die
inflation etwas mit unterbrochenen
lieferketten und sondereffekten zu tun
aber lassen wir nicht aus den augen in
diesem zusammenhang die politik unsere
europäischen notenbank die ezb musste
aufgrund der enormen
verschuldungssituation in europa zu
künstlich niedrigen zinsen greifen zu
anleiheankaufprogramm sie hat deshalb
gar nicht mehr das instrumentarium wie
die amerikanische notenbank um auf die
inflation zu reagieren und deshalb armin
laschet der sagt erreicht nicht mit dem
taschenrechner nach brüssel deshalb herr
scholz der sie hier von integration
sprechen erwarten wir ein klares
statement auch noch vor der
bundestagswahl das deutschland in der
nächsten legislaturperiode
weiter ich sage besser wieder anwalt von
stabilität in europa ist die
finanzpolitische eigenverantwortung der
mitglieder der wirtschaft und währung
jung muss unser anliegen bleiben
machen wir die
sozialversicherungssysteme nachhaltig
der demografische wandel droht unsere
sozialkassen zu überfordern und
alimentierung mag edlen motiven folgen
nachhaltig ist sie nicht das gros der
menschen will eben nicht transfer
sondern faire chancen auf einen job und
deshalb muss das neue gesellschaftliche
politik projekt die erneuerung des
aufstiegs versprechens eine gute bildung
ist dazu der schlüssel
wir müssen dafür sorgen dass der eigene
wohlstand nicht durch das elternhaus
vorgezeichnet wird es ist zeit dass wir
bildung auch für den bund zu einem
schlüsselprojekt machen damit der bund
investieren darf in kitas schulen und
hochschulen dass wir eine
exzellenzinitiative bekommen nicht nur
für die hochschulen sondern für den
beruflichen bereich das
kooperationsverbot muss fallen und für
die menschen die trotz arbeitslosigkeit
in eine schwere lebenskrise geraten muss
es aufstiegschancen geben er scheut sich
sprechen von 12 euro mindestlohn wer
einen minijob hat hat dadurch kein
höheres einkommen sondern wird gezwungen
weniger zu arbeiten das allein hilft
menschen nicht und wie viele menschen im
mindestlohn haben einen manager was ist
mit der allein erziehenden mutter im
hartz-iv-bezug der wollen sie wenn sie
an minijob hat zwar den mindestlohn
erhören aber die zuverdienstgrenzen die
sind nicht erhöht die wird weiter 80
prozent ihres zuverdienst abgeben um das
ist der größte skandal der aufstiegs
gerechtigkeit in deutschland und deshalb
wir stehen vor richtungsentscheidungen
in diesem land unsere botschaft ist klar
freiheit vor staat erwirtschaften vor
verteilen und mehr freude am erfinden
als an verbieten
[Applaus]